yeah that's what that's the way to do it  like honestly if you get married first  a man feels more obliged to stay with  the woman  i don't i don't know why you think it's  the other way around like not the other  way around is what is she going to get  down on her knee or are you going to get  down on your knee you're getting down on  your knee so that means you've already  committed to what you're going to do  right yeah but don't you think that's  because they're frightening divorce and  they think oh well you know she's going  to take off my assets  it's like it's pretty expensive to get a  prenup you got 10k laying around i mean  if you're gonna risk half your wealth  going then i should have 10k laying  around if i'm going to have a white  dress  i'm saying that's the reason a lot of  guys don't do it is it is expensive um  and i just know this because i have a  couple friends that have gone through  the process and they just like the the  cost didn't  make sense to them